okay now let's go to the good ron
desantis
all right a little bit of a palette
cleanser here rhonda sanders gave a
press conference yesterday
what a contrast between what you just
saw from asa hutchinson and this year
uh the press conference the whole thing
was great but i loved especially when we
get towards the end speaking directly to
biden let's uh let's play this
joe biden is taken to himself to try to
single out florida
over kovid this is a guy who ran for
president saying he was going to quote
shut down the virus and what has he done
he's imported more virus from around the
world by having a wide open southern
border
you have hundreds of thousands of people
pouring across
every month and it's not just from
mexico in fact it's rarely from mexico
you have over a hundred different
countries where people are pouring
through
not only are they letting them through
they're then farming them out
all across our communities across this
country putting them on planes
putting them on buses do you think
they're being
worried about covid for that of course
not so he's facilitating who knows what
new variants are out there
but i can tell you whatever variants are
around the world they're coming across
that southern border
and so he's not shutting down the virus
he's helping to facilitate it in our
country
why don't you do your job why don't you
get this border secure
and until you do that i don't want to
hear a blip
about covid from you thank you
there it is he's exactly right about the
border of course
that joe biden is inviting into the
country
hordes of infected people and just
letting them in letting them in to
spread the the virus it's you can look
at a map
of where covid is is spreading the most
right now and where the where the
biggest spikes and cases are
and wouldn't you know i mean what a
coincidence that
so many of these big spikes are
happening down south near the border
what a crazy it's like you know i i
don't know again
again not an epidemiologist but it just
seems like you're
opening up the border you're inviting
people in we know that hundreds and
thousands of these people are infected
with covid
and then and then around the areas where
they're coming in we're seeing spikes in
cases
it's like you might actually draw some
sort of connection i don't know
so he's exactly right of course about
everything that he said um
joe biden is facilitating the spread of
the virus
and he knows that's what he's doing to
the extent that he knows
anything anymore to the extent that he
knows what he's doing at all in general
in life
to the extent that he that he knows that
he's eating breakfast while he eats it
he knows what he's doing down
on the border is doing it intentionally
and rhonda sans is exactly right about
that and this is this is what we need
from republicans
again the contrast between asa
hutchinson utterly ineffectual
useless and then ron desantis who is
really getting things done as a governor
you don't play defense the other
contrast here is asa hutchinson playing
defense
oh no i'm sorry i didn't mean it you're
putting the shield up hiding behind the
podium practically
he was all but ducking behind the podium
don't yell at me i'm sorry
um that's defense whereas ron desantis
is going right after them
and doing it in meaningful ways
which is why ron desantis
should be considered our front runner
runner for 2024.
i mean yeah it's still still far away he
hasn't officially announced
that he's running for president yet if
he does run
listen every time i say this i know it
upsets a certain portion of the audience
who don't want to hear it but
at this point looking forward to what is
a likely scenario
in the republican primaries for 2024
where you've got a whole field of people
and behind that field is at front donald
trump and ron desantis
there is no reason
to support a 78 year old donald trump
over ron desantis in 2024 except
just that you're invested in a
personality called
like at this point assuming that both of
those guys are
in the running and are an option for
voters if you're going with trump it's
it's because you're in the personality
cult there cannot be any other reason
there really can't
78 years old he's going to turn he's as
old as biden he will be as old as biden
when he gets to 2024.
so you're giving him a second shot in
his 80s
to accomplish some things that frankly
look trump to accomplish some things
that trump never even came close to
accomplishing the first time didn't even
try
even simple things like drain the swamp
could we be honest with each other trump
did not drain the swamp
didn't try to made no attempt
in fact he surrounded himself with the
swamp
and listened to them for four years
did their bidding that's that's the
truth
he had trump had very little interest in
in the
act of actually governing
and also is trump's two biggest flaws
okay
little interest in the actual act of
governing the the work of governing
especially the boring stuff
the stuff you're doing behind the scenes
where you're really governing
little interest in doing that and um
also
trump always cared deeply what people
said about him
and how they and how they felt about him
and so he spent the entire four years
defending himself
personally and he was also on the other
side of it he's susceptible to flattery
so if you flattered him
he would let you into the circle and
listen to you
um ronda sanders doesn't have those
flaws
not saying he's flawless he's a
politician they've i mean all people
have flaws politicians especially
but those are not flaws that he has he
is very interested in the act of
governing
he's very good at it and he doesn't seem
to be
he doesn't seem to really care what
anyone says
and there's no evidence that you can
flatter your way into his heart and
manipulate him that way
so almost all of the good points of
trump are shared by
desantis and most of the bad points are
not shared
and he's a lot younger um and he's a
rising star
so to me it's an easy decision
i i just i that i would like for someone
to make a case for me for trump over
desantis
that goes beyond personality cold stuff
if you could do it i'd be interested to
hear well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt well show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content